joe biden made a quick trip to florida
today
his first time in the sunshine state for
nearly a year
well it turns out his 2020 basement
strategy
has him looking a little vulnerable and
at times
even a tad confused harris biden
administration is going to relaunch that
effort
when we hit the recession
the president at president obama and it
frightens people when i talk about
the testing area they're really shooting
live ammo and things and
yeah meanwhile trump is signing historic
peace accords getting two nobel prize
nominations
and crisscrossing the country now over
the past 36 hours
the president was in nevada for a rally
california to deal with the wildfires
arizona for a hispanic event then back
to washington
to sign the abraham accords and after
all that
he then headed to pennsylvania for a
town hall tonight
which will have as i said first reaction
later in the hour
trump is truly the energizer bunny of
politics keeps going and going
now for biden though a big day is
i don't know casting a primary vote just
a few minutes drive from his home
and what about early voting you guys
voted early today because i'm gonna be
in where am i tomorrow
since biden himself can't tell us uh
it's important that we examine
the twin forces behind the biden
candidacy
the billionaires and the bolsheviks and
explain
what each faction wants now when michael
bloomberg announced that he was giving
the biden campaign
a hundred million dollars to spend in
florida
it became obvious that the billionaire
class is getting a little nervous
suddenly the goal of getting back to
normal and our relationship with china
which is what they want
it doesn't seem such a sure bet after
all
now bloomberg hates the trump tariffs
because they make it harder to do big
deals in china
and offshore more u.s jobs both of which
he ends up favoring
now of course he's just one of at least
132 prominent billionaires
who are supporting biden first there's
bill gates
who seems to be rooting for a biden win
in november as well after all he and
biden
both share the same agenda they both
agree on appeasing china
a national mask mandate and no return to
normalcy without a vaccine
for the world at large normalcy only
returns
when we've largely vaccinated the entire
global population
i love how he does this with his hands
well then there's tom steyer of course
who
is a rabid promoter of the green new
deal which we already know will cost
trillions and kill the oil and gas
industry
oh and there's also lauren powell jobs
the wife of the late apple founder
whose magazine the atlantic just
published that bogus smear
claiming trump belittled our war dead
false
well they all have one thing in common
they absolutely despise
president trump's america first agenda
the billionaire crowd prefers an america
where there's always a glut of labor now
what does that mean it means
there's no pressure on companies to
raise wages
trump prefers a tight labor market that
puts
upward pressure on wagers meaning
bringing them up that's good for the
average working person
besides the billionaires don't really
they don't need a functioning government
they certainly don't have to worry much
about law and order
they have security guards and big walls
and helicopters and planes if they want
to escape
but not the average person now check out
this headline
pennsylvania's blue-collar voters see
danger and back
trump now these same workers they know
the truth
trump's economic nationalism works and
these same workers know the truth that
trump's econom economic nationalism
is nothing that biden would ever agree
to in fact he works against it now
check out this headline median household
income increased 6.8
to 68 700 the highest on record now the
nation's poverty rate fell by 1.3
percentage points
to 10.5 percent of course this was uh in
2019
that was down from 11.8 percent in 2018.
this marked the lowest rate since
estimates were first published
in 1959 and it was the fifth
consecutive decline now this was real
money
in americans pockets all before the
pandemic
and if biden wins there's going to be no
repeating the 2019
fantastic numbers because we'll be in
lockdown as i said last night with
massive job losses and stagnating wages
oh we're going to be hit with a 4
trillion tax increase as well
now the only thing that will trickle
down from all of this
is poverty government dependence
now the other force supporting biden are
the modern day bolsheviks
the aoc plus three types o plus antifa
as far as the eye can see they believe
that america
is an awful rotten racist country and
they
plan to punish anyone who gets in the
way
of their cultural revolution aoc's tweet
yesterday is characteristic of how she
feels about us
the fact of the matter is the united
states is engaged in a program of mass
human rights violations targeting
immigrants this includes a mass child
separation systemic sexual assault
police and detention people in detention
kangaroo court procedures and more
our country must atone for it all
hmm of course she's talking about
illegal immigrants
not legal immigrants now the radical
fringe
they are going to let billionaires run
economic policy
as long as they can run everything else
so aoc is fine as long as she can do
climate policy
have a say in the courts the doj
that's because they'll use every tool in
the government's power
to harass americans who defy
the socialist edicts it's going to be a
long
dark period of recriminations and
retribution
and don't think for a second that biden
or kamala harris or anyone else
will even try to slam the brakes on as
we speed towards socialism this is our
time to make sure
we get rid of trump and we elect someone
who is going to be responsive
to the policy positions we are
advocating for
joe biden has put probably the boldest
plan i've ever seen in my lifetime
to be by 2035 carbon neutral what came
out of those task forces
were pretty strong progressive programs
joe biden is prepared to do that
now biden is being propped up by the
energy
of the left that loathes america more
than it really likes him
along with the money of some of the
richest men and women on the planet
but neither the billionaires nor the
bolsheviks
have much interest in building a strong
middle class
the billionaires don't like workers who
can think for themselves and
the bolsheviks they don't like the
masses to be independent of government
control
they form kind of an unholy alliance to
turn the whole country
into a giant version of baltimore with a
tiny number of rich people
people and a lot of poor people but the
middle class
guess what it still gets to vote and if
we want to preserve our way
of life if we want to keep the good jobs
that have been created in recent years
and
the freedoms that americans have enjoyed
for centuries
will reject biden the billionaires and
the neo-bolsheviks
and that's the angle